we have some breaking news I want to
bring in Julie Hyman at the breaking
news desk Jules what do you have
apparently thieves have used the IRS
online service system to access private
information from 104,000 returns of
taxpayers this according to an IRS
official Commissioner who's been
speaking on a call with reporters there
was unauthorized access according to him
from February through mace obviously
encompassing the high time of the tax
filing season again he says there was
access to 104,000 returns from taxpayers
apparently it included the tax returns
and other tax information on file with
the IRS and this was through some sort
of online service called get transit get
transcript of the thieves cleared of
security screen the required knowledge
about the taxpayer including their
social security number date of birth tax
filing status and street address so it
sounds like they might have had some
information already and use this to gain
more access we'll bring you more as we
get more headlines from that call